they're going to resign mr rabb
did he do all he could to help
vulnerable afghans when lives were on
the line
today dominic raab was in the office
speaking to foreign counterparts but
where was this international
coordination before the taliban took
control it's a call he didn't make that
has led to pressure for him to quit on
friday officials urged the foreign
secretary to urgently call hanif atma
his opposite number in kabul to try and
help afghans who'd worked with uk forces
escaped the country
but mr raab was on holiday here the
amarandes hotel resort in crete it
markets itself as for the privileged and
perceptive
yet the foreign secretary clearly didn't
perceive the political danger and didn't
make that call
could it have made a difference to
desperate afghans now being processed by
british soldiers at kabul airport the
defense secretary doesn't think so one
phone call is not the reason we are
where we are at the moment and i don't
even know if that phone call deal didn't
happen because all we have is a media
speculative front page about it but if
as the defense secretary claims
afghanistan's government was melting
away on friday why did the prime
minister head off on holiday on saturday
and why was the foreign secretary still
abroad on holiday on sunday all of this
feeds into a wider perception that those
working here at the foreign office and
across government lacked leadership at a
critical time
opponents in parliament are keen to
capitalize he's lost the confidence of
the house of commons there's real anger
out there in the country and he still
hasn't got a plan in place to deal with
it that's why we say he has to resign
dominic raab seems safe for now the same
cannot be said for those in these images
but if more evidence emerges of
opportunities missed pressure on the
foreign secretary could mount joe pike
sky news westminster